[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الشهر السادس من شهور السنه الميلاديه
يسمى بيونيو ويونيو احد الاربعه شهور الذي
يتكون من ثلاثين يوما يسمى بالعراق وبلاد
شام بحزيران والمغرب العربي يسمونه بجوان
ومصر يسمونه ديون واصل التسميه ماخوذه من
جون وهي زوجه الهه السماء الروماني جوبيتر
والذي يحب زوجته كثيرا اني احبك حبا لو
علمت به لازهر الكون في عينيك
ازدهرت
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وشهر يونيو في اوله تبدا مربعانيه القيل
وهي الاربعين يوما السابقه على الحر
اللاهب والمسماه عند العامه بزاد
وفي منتصفه ينتهي الموسم الطبيعي لنزول
الامطار على بلدان الخليج ما عدا سلطنه
عمان واليمن وجنوب السعوديه فهذه تبدا
عندهم موسم الامطار الخريفيه وفي نهايته
نعيش اطول نهر واقصر ليالي السنه وترد
الشمس بارحه الى الجهه الجنوبيه البارحه
يا حبيبي ضاقي صدري والقلب حزن على فرقه
حبيبه يا من يرد الحبيب وياخذ اجري قفا
بلا سبه
ربي حسيبه
[موسيقى]